let's talk a little bit about Republican
reactions to failed former president
Donald Trump having this white
supremacist dinner with Nick Fuentes and
Kanye West and others at Mar-A-Lago Mike
Pence does something which is it's
almost difficult to do in a sense Mike
Pence will come around
and make a statement supposedly based on
principle and whatever and it's like the
blandest most milk toast most
meaningless statement he could possibly
make that just Falls so embarrassingly
and humiliatingly short of what people
should be saying so as an example of the
type of reaction that I would like to
see more from Republicans just figure uh
just to find rather
the recent statement from Mitt Romney
which I don't have here available but is
widely available uh on just completely
unequivocal unquestioning condemnation
of this dinner that Donald Trump had
Mike Pence on the other hand
wants Donald Trump to apologize for the
dinner with the anti-semite apologies I
think he should apologize the Associated
Press has an article about it we have
the clip let's take a look at it here is
Mike Pence on news nation and
um he wants an apology and all the way
by the way notice there's a butt here as
well president Trump was wrong uh to
give a white nationalist
an anti-semite and a holocaust denier or
a seat at the table and uh I think he
should apologize for it uh wow you
should really apologize for that that
was the wrong thing to do you should
denounce those individuals uh and their
hateful rhetoric without qualification
with that being said as I point out in
the book with that being said you know
there's other stuff I need to mention
here because well I
I don't believe Donald Trump is an
anti-semite I don't believe he's a
racist or a bigot I would not have been
his vice president if he was that's a
lie now that that that's that's where it
starts to get unbelievable you wouldn't
have been his vice president come on
Mike we don't believe that you were
thirsty for power in the spotlight a guy
comes to you who's the nominee and he
says I want you to be my running mate
and you go uh I don't know I mean you're
you're kind of a little bit racist so I
can't I'm not gonna do it nobody
believes that and uh you know people
often forget the the president's
daughter converted to Judaism yeah
son-in-law is a devout Jew
um his grandchildren he's a Jew so
listen we've talked about this before
um it's less with Trump about I've also
made some of the same observations that
Mike Pence is making here uh Jared
Kushner his son-in-law is Jewish his own
daughter converted to Judaism his
grandkids some of his grandkids are now
Jewish with Trump it's not about the
type of anti-Semitism that would have
him denounce his own daughter it's about
similar to Trump with his preconceived
notions about people from certain
countries or same with Trump when it
comes to his views on lgbtq individuals
it's not the type of virulence
phobia or isms that some of my former
guests on the show have exhibited but it
is more of like a low-grade casual here
is my sort of beliefs about these people
and he tolerates them in whatever the
case may be but he's not so against the
racism and xenophobia and whatever that
he will unilaterally denounce it from
his movement and reject individuals who
do Harbor those views that's the type of
view and type of person that Donald
Trump is and and Views that he holds now
as far as Mike Pence here okay this is
both too little and too late when it
comes to Mike Pence and in fact it's
quite pathetic and what I mean for about
that is the following
if these
right-wing Republicans like Pence
wanted us to really believe
that they are completely against the
type of views espoused by Fuentes and
Kanye West and I don't even remember was
Milo yiannopoulos part of that dinner I
don't know I don't remember exactly who
was there
it would be more powerful
if they denounce the people within their
own parties that had these views because
there's members of the Republican Party
who are elected officials in the House
of Representatives and to some degree
even in the Senate who have a variety of
these views and there they are silent
and so it's easy to call out Nick
Fuentes or Kanye West and people who are
being not universally but but at least
by some political movements denounced
it's easy to do that call out the
elected officials in your party this is
too little too late for Mike Pence and
now I want to talk about Mitch McConnell
as well
one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa I have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs I have not one but
two all form sofas I've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable Furniture I own and
it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and arm chairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below